America loves a
superstar I'm Jason two J's Jennings I
was a football legend but once you reach
the Mountaintop of greatness everybody
wants to see you
fall two days this guy
smoked damn you plad guilty to charges
of speeding and damage to city property
I'm recommending community service with
the Long Beach Recreations department I
thought I was getting like some Martha
Stewart kind of treatment you too good
for the community that raised you from
the
deaths I am football legend Jason 2 J's
Jennings your new head coach leing let
me get a picture with y'all real quick
for Twitter some of y'all going to get
some girlfriends but this right
here Keys Karem Jason I've been trying
to get back to touch on you for years
years I know you've been thinking about
me and I know you've been trying to get
in touch with me is that pretty much
right you just put a gun in my head
relax Jay the safety was on oh no it
wasn't on what imagine
that before we can be the best we got to
master the
fundamentals pretty boy you missing pass
after pass you got on all that sweet ass
swag the next time you come out here
acting like a fake ass rapper we going
to kick your ass off the field stop
acting like you got an album coming
out JJ how you liking this game coach
this is a mess I don't know what I'm
doing do you remember what you were like
when you showed up freshman year you
were pain in the ass I don't owe nobody
nothing sound just like me if you really
want to win a game stop pushing away
your
team let's
go it look like a black princess layer
underdogs on three underdogs on Me 1 2 3
my
[Music]
name I got your mascots right here be
killer and squiller two calls for 2 G's
I found them chained up in the back of
the winter
snitches